let's talk about Sarah Palin and her
family because there's a surprising turn
that we have to tell you about ET
breaking news tonight daughter Bristol
is officially married to the man she
dumped last year practically at the
altar we have the exclusive photos of
the newly married couple on their
honeymoon in a secret location and in a
statement only two et Bristol and Dakota
say quote life is full of ups and downs
but in the end you'll end up where
you're supposed to be we are so happy to
share the wonderful news that we got
married
Bristol poses with a glittering diamond
ring Dakota's wedding band is all black
it's definitely challenging and that's
just it's been a contentious year for
the 25 year-old mother of two and her 27
year old groom they were engaged for two
months last year until Bristol called it
off just days before the wedding but
during our interview with Bristol's mom
Sarah Palin if she suggested her
daughter was bouncing back versus doing
great with the babies and working
full-time the couple have been hinting
about their reconciliation on social
media recently et can also confirm
Bristol and Dakota are asking the court
to add his surname to their five month
old daughter so she'll be sailor grace
Palin Meyer